alles dreht sich am freitagabend im
dancing stars power um um die dame
zulegen
ruxandra ist es der erste sohle dann
sind dieser stadt
die 2
sehr aufregend ich kann mich eigentlich
gar nicht so jetzt genau an alles
passiert es also glücklich es ist das
wirtschaft haben eigentlich die
hebefiguren in ordnung waren und beide
eltern von der aktion haben geweint
das ist ein positives zeichen finde ich
bin ich
das war mit dieser melodie von könig der
löwen irgendwie mehr genau bevor einer
großen geschichte beschlossen
auch mama sabine kann ihre tränen nicht
zurückhalten als tochter wuchs an ihre
ersten schritte am parkett musste sich
überraschen lassen natürlich berührt
offenbar auf die jury für den tanz von
raw zahnrad gibt es bestnoten bekommen
haben im juli von heute
ich hoffe das wird teil davon war die
unsere militärische unterstützung heute
gemeint ist peter rapp der in der weißen
ausgehuniform des österreichischen
bundesheeres erscheint die wahl
panzerfahrer bin als zugführer
abgerüstet ein wenig die amateur jakob
war er als leiter abgelöst aber so bin
ich heute als scharfer hieb unheimlich
für führerschein gehabt
damals gab eine ganze reihe von panzern
im 47 km x3cc vierer 30 sarah spz dann
habe ich diesmal gemacht haflinger hat
die äußerung war 15 monate bayer das war
langweilig also bin ich mit jedem
geträumt fahren was man unterm hintern
druckt an in der kommenden woche muss
das erste tanzpaar den ball und
verlassen
es muss eine dame sein wenigste woche
geht das haben haben die damen sich
meiner meinung nach viel schlechter als
ich präsentiere als die herren die
letzte woche
dancing stars am freitag um 20 15 in orf